[Music]
hi i'm linda i'm otherwise known as
salty seattle and i'm a pasta artist i
share most of my posture creations on
instagram because instagram is such a
perfect medium for just really visually
arresting and delicious things today
we're making all of the colors for
rainbow papridella and we go through the
entire color of the rainbow and it's not
arbitrary we continue to build on each
new color the first color of pasta dough
i'm going to make is blue i use a
special flower called the butterfly pea
flower and it grows on a vine and it's
bright blue and it's native to southeast
asia to make purple pasta dough i love
to use a mixture of dragon fruit and
blueberry and i like to use double zero
pasta flour because the texture is
supple and it has a very low gluten
slash protein content for the next pasta
dough color it'll be red and so i like
to mix together beets and harissa and
beets by themselves are really pink and
so you add the harissa in there to sort
of offset that pinkness and give it a
little bit more of a true red
today i'm using harissa to achieve my
orange pasta dough but you could also
use paprika to achieve this color i use
turmeric to make the yellow pasta dough
and i love to use the whole turmeric
root rather than the powder for the last
pasta dough i'm going to go with bright
green and in order to achieve that
bright cream i use parsley and i like to
mix just a tiny little bit of turmeric
with it
so to make the
rainbow we're going to do rainbow
stripes and we use this cutter for the
pasta machine called the fettuccine
cutter to make our strips of different
colors of pasta dough
so now we have our stripes placed on our
base sheet and we're going to run it
back through the pasta machine if you
don't have a pasta machine and you
want to make pasta anyway just use a
rolling pin the cool thing about pasta
dough is you can re-roll it and re-roll
it and re-roll it and you're not going
to hurt it as long as it doesn't dry out
too much i think i really honed my pasta
making skill though living in italy and
just learning from grandmas and kind of
learning their specific noodle that they
were really passionate about
i'm making caramel pasta and i'm using
this really gorgeous magenta dough and
combining it with a yellow it's a bright
turmeric
sunny yolk colored yellow these tools
that i'm using right now are actually
for i think probably more common for
like cake and cookie decorating i always
have pasta on my mind and i'm always
thinking about like tools that i could
potentially repurpose and use for pasta
the filling is made of ricotta cheese
and some nutmeg salt and a little bit of
sugar
caramel means candies in italian which
you probably could have guessed just by
looking at their shape
pasta is a course and you do not serve
anything with the pasta it should be
loved and appreciated and admired for
itself as a course
the pasta shape we're making now is
called garganelli they have ridges on
them which sauce just loves to cling to
this is a pasta bike you can cut squares
and rectangles with this thing
if you want to serve it with something
that's really hearty and substantial
then a thicker pasta can really stand up
to that really i would say that thinness
is a matter of personal preference
[Music]
i always grew up wanting to do art and
probably ultimately came down to finding
the right medium and it just feels right
in my hands
[Music]
you